There may come a time when you want to send an email to multiple people at once,...
...at which point you may wish to make use of the CC feature.
Now, if you take one thing away from this talk, let it be the CC rule.
The CC rule states that primary recipients of an email,...
...who are expected to respond, should go in the "To" field.
Other recipients of an email, who are not expected to respond...
...and who are included as a courtesy or for their information,...
...should go in the "CC" field.
Next time you receive an email that's been addressed to multiple people, take a look:...
...Are you a primary recipient, or are you on CC?
Do you need to respond?
What I love about the CC rule is it makes the expectations on your recipients so clear.
If you're in the "To" field, you should respond;...
...if you're on the "CC" field, you should not respond.
And it also reduces the burden of email by hopefully cutting back on the number of emails sent.
Those people on CC don't have that awkward moment where they're wondering,...
..."Am I expected to pitch in here?"
The CC rule will change your email life.